[موسيقى]
اهلا ومرحبا بكم اعزا المشاهدين الى هذه
الجوله عبر المجلات الاسبوعيه التقيناها
لحضراتكم
الغلاف والملف الرئيسي
لاحتجاجات الغضب في ايران المتواصله والتي
دخلت شهرها الرابع تتناول الموضوع من عده
زوايا من بين الزوايا للمثيره للاهتمام هو
حلف ما تسميها الحلف الدموي بين الرئيس
ابراهيم رئيسي وبين الحرس الثوري الايراني
وهذه اختيار هذه الاجابه اجابه القمع
الدموي لهذه الاحتجاجات
وسلسله الاعداء في حقي المواطنين
الايرانيين ثاني مجازين تتحدث عن موضوع
اخر او عن هذه فقدان السيطره بالنسبه
لنظام الايراني ومن زاويه اخرى زاويه
الاحتباس الحراري وتغير المناخ وهي تشير
الى ان المهمه الصعبه لاستعاده الزمام
المبادره والسيطره على الامور في ظل ما
تسميه ازمه المياه والجفاف المستفحل في
ايران جراء الاحتباس الحراري في هذه
المجلات ايضا ننتقل في موضوع اخر الى
فضيحه هزت اركانه او اصبت المانيا بالصدمه
هذه فضيحه اكتشاف جاسوس
لصالح روسيا في قلب البستان المجله تشير
الى هذه الحرب الاخرى التي
تقوم بها روسيا
بالموازنات مع الحرب الاوكرانيه وهي حرب
الجواسيس التي تعيد الى الوجه تاريخ الحرب
البارده من جديد في قلب المانيا حرب
الجواسيسه وفي مجالات هذا الاسبوع حديث عن
تاريخي همم لون بيرغيز او الامبراطوريه
الروسيه من ايفون تغيب ايفان ال الفظيعه
الى فلاديمير بوتين مرورا بالستالين
وكاتخين العظيمه وهذه هذا التاريخ الدموي
الذي يعيد نفسه في روسيا في فرن بوليسيه
هذا الاسبوع حديث عن العلاقات الامريكيه
الصينيه وهذه المواجهه المحتومه المجله
تتساءل هل حضر الرئيس بيضا وديموقراطيين
السياسه لاستشراف هذه المواجهه التي لا
مفر منها سؤال يبقى مطروحا وفي فرن
بوليسيه حديثا عن هذا الرجل
ياما الذي همم اصدر كتابه الاخير لمن لا
يعرفه يا ما هو من وضع نظريه نهايه
التاريخ بعد سقوط او انهيار الاتحاد
السوفيتي وهو يعود اليوم بنظريه اخرى او
بتساؤل اخر عن القيم ما الذي تبقى من قيم
الديمقراطيه والليبراليه في العالم وفي
الولايات المتحده بين ارث الترامبيه من
جهه وبين عدم قدره الديمقراطيين على بلوره
صيغه او احياء نفس جديد للديمقراطيه
والدفاع عنها وهو يتخوف فوكوياما من ان
تواجه الولايات المتحده نفس المصير التي
واجهه الاتحاد السوفيتي بنهاري قيامها
الديمقراطيه والاخلاقيه هذا تساؤل كبير
جدا في مجالات هذا الاسبوع حديث عن
المونديال بطبيعه الحال كوريان تغنيسيونال
تضعوا جرد حساب لهذا المونديال العربي
وتنقل عن الصحف هذه الاشاده بتنظيم قد غدر
ونجاحها في تنظيم هذا الموضوع للاستثنائي
ولكن في صحف اخرى حديثا عن ما غيره اما
جلبه هذا المونديال الى المنطقه العربيه
فانه تقول واد همم زمن الربيع العربي
وادخل المنطقه العربيه وادما في منظومه
العولمه الليبراليه وعن المونديال دائما
باريمات تتحدث عن هذا المعجزه ميسي
المعجزه الذي حاز احرز الكاس وهذه في خيبه
الامل ام مبابي الذي ينظر الى هذه الكاس
بحسره ولكن بعد ماتش تقول سنعود مغذي غرام
بعد اربع سنوات
وتطيب خاطره لملا بغيا تتحدث عن هذا الارث
في الفرنسي لا ليس مهم ان لم نحرز الكاس
ولكن العالم مدين لفرنسا بالعديد من
الانجازات التاريخيه ليس فقط البيجات
والبغيه والمطبخ الفرنسي ولكن ايضا روح
الشعب والثوره اتت من فرنسا تكتب ماغيان
الفرنسيه في مجلات هذا الاسبوع حديث هذا
المقال الهام جدا عن ما تسميه النيل ذو ار
كيولوجيك هذا موقع العلا الاثري في
المملكه العربيه السعوديه وهو يقع هنا
انظر هذا في الشمال الشرقي للمملكه
العربيه السعوديه هذا الموقع الذي يعود
تاريخه الى القرن الرابع ميلادي ويسبق
ميلاد النبي محمد بثلاث مئه سنه هو اليوم
محل تنقيب فرنسي سعودي لسبري اغباء اغوار
هذه المنطقه قبل ظهور الاسلام وهذا امر
مثير جدا للاهتمام لمانيتي مجازين وعاشيه
اعياد الميلاد تخصص هذه الاولى ليسوع
المسيح عيسى ابن مريم وهو ترسمه لمن يتم
القريبه من الحزب الشيوعي الفرنسي ترسمه
يسوع على انه اول الثائرين عن المنظومه
همم القائمه الاجتماعيه وبالتالي تتساءل
ربما يكون اول
الشيوعيين لما لا
بهذا اعزائي المشاهدين ننهي هذه الجوله
لبس نريكم هنا فقط في عجاله هذه الاولى
لذلكوناميست بمناسبه نهايه راس السنه
والاعياد نتمنى لكم اعيادا مجيده وكل عام
وانتم بالف خير الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]